the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
[Music]
welcome everybody to the 2022 summer
chess classic here at the saint louis
chess club we have two very strong
ground robin tournaments to bring to you
guys to bring all the action i'm grand
master alejandra ramirez here with grand
master christian curiela alejandro
always a pleasure to be here in studio b
with you casting the games of uh some of
the best chess players that we have here
in saint louis what can you tell us
about the two events that we have but
before we get into that we do have some
breaking news tell us about that some
breaking news are not the happiest of
news unfortunately uh kovit does strike
the classic and ray robson unfortunately
had to withdraw from the tournament as
he tested positive this morning his
results so far against yu yang yi uh
gregory opparin and abby manumisra are
annulled for the purposes of the
tournament remember that there will be
ratings still counted for it not too
much for
uh ray he's scored 50 percent
and luckily that doesn't impact the
standings as much because he actually
made three draws he did not win he did
not lose so it doesn't impact the
standings and their individual results
as much quite nice but tell us a bit
about uh standings in group a alejandro
what can you tell us about that let's
take a look and remember that uh some of
these players actually have
uh the result out of two games so for
example uh abhimanyu mishra gregorio
parent ayumyanyi there's called one and
a half out of two one half out of two
and half out of two so not out of three
the rest of the players are on the basis
of three games and currently that means
that benjamin gladura and jonas beer are
leading the tournament with two points
each you could argue that both yu yang
yi and ami
are also there with a plus one score but
they haven't gotten there so far exactly
so benjamin gledura jonas beer they are
way ahead of the pack but they haven't
played uh ray robson so they will have a
buy round in which they will not gain a
single point yes that's right not a full
point and not a half point either as the
results are being annulled instead of
just a half point by
absolutely and
what can you tell us about group b
alejandro well groupie we got everybody
so no real issues in this one it's four
players at the top collegiate players
all of them which is quite interesting
brandon jacobs from camille dragoon
guillermo vazquez and jj ali marande are
all sitting pretty with a plus one score
two out of three both uh vasquez and ali
marandi have a full point from
yesterday's game both of them winning
and
and tied for uh fifth position we have
uh misha antipo for university from
university of missouri christopher you
zuzon ciao who is actually playing misha
on tip of today
tied for the eighth position we have
nico checker and john burke who lost
yesterday against guillermo vasquez and
in seoul last 10th position we have
tigran harold union yes and tell us a
little bit about the format of this
tournament christian well the format of
the tournament is quite simple it's a 10
player round robin we have two of those
one of them unfortunately only has nine
players left 90 minutes for the first 40
moves 30 minutes for the rest of the
game the players are also gaining 30
second increment starting from move one
and how about the schedule alejandro
well the schedule is simple as well it's
one round a day with every round
starting at 1 pm central of course on
the last day on friday june 10th we'll
actually start two hours earlier at 11
am to accommodate the potential playoffs
in case that we need them on the last
after the last round to determine the
winner of the tournaments and of course
we start our broadcast two and a half
hours into the tournament starting every
single day that is no exception on
friday june 10th will be starting at 1
30 pm instead of our usual 3 30. and
let's not forget you the audience can
also engage with us via social media you
can reach us at
summer chess classic on twitter
we are definitely very engaging on
social media as well and you can follow
this program both on twitch and on
youtube also on twitch and youtube you
can also donate tell us a bit about that
alejandro where does
that donation go to believe it or not
those donations do not line our pockets
here in the studio they actually go
directly into charity you'll be able to
sponsor a full semester of chess
programming for a child you'll be able
to help talented youth as well as at
risk youth receive chess lessons to help
them in so many so many things the st
louis chess club does everything from
scholastic chess at the very beginning
just to all the way to the elite events
passing through the summer classic which
is almost elite but not quite there so
help us out every 75 dollars helps a ton
absolutely and
your kid will get the best tutoring
possible here in the united states from
top level coaches such as varujon
okobian one of our friends here in st
louis and how about the pairings
alejandro what's happening in group a
in group a we only have four games but
four very interesting games
uh i think yu yang yi against elias
miriam would definitely be an
interesting one griego yoparion against
theodore is great glendora against
sevien absolutely fantastic but
my focus is going to be in this game
between jonas beer and ambi manu mishra
two of the youngest players actually two
youngest players in the a group 17 years
of age and 13 respectively and they're
both leading technically the tournament
because even though one and a half
points has a mania mishra those are out
of two as you can see on his standings
yes
plus one for both players and i actually
want to go to that game directly because
it might not
last all that long from the position we
have currently yeah
yeah we've been looking at this position
for a while uh between christian and i
and we thought that black was busted but
again remember that we're not using
engines so we were not guaranteeing that
they were busted but it seems like this
it looks really bad yeah this one is one
one good move away it feels from
from collapsing black's position i don't
think you need any like spectacular
moves
before right right it's just queen takes
before the knight on b5 is hitting the
rook on c7 also by the way it's unclear
if that's the best move what if i just
simply go queen to e2
we need to i think
that
the the point of black is to go like
rook c7 to d7 that's fine
and
i again i get what you're saying that
queen two is also looking good i what's
obviously better right right and there's
a lot of good ideas the thing is after
queen takes before actually queen takes
before is just i just didn't see how you
defend your stuff the only move i could
have thought of was rook d7
with the idea that you have if you take
take take the work on d1 will be hanging
at the end and if you do take on d7 then
the knight from b6 can take back and
defend at the same time the knight on c5
right that being said even if that is
achievable for black even at the end
you're really getting another point you
can take one exam you can also take on
f6 force you to take with the g pawn
mm-hmm
i mean and then take on a7
oh my goodness i mean this is two extra
pawns better king
everything and everything is protected
everything is defended the bishop is
defended the queen is okay the knight
will come back to play on g5 go back to
b5 the knights are kind of stepping on
each other
this one is just over i have to say
probably mishra
will be resigning very soon uh but this
is such a big result for jonas beer such
a great start
beating nicolas and then beating mishra
it's a it's a dream start oh yeah for
the dane i don't think we'll see a
resignation any time soon because now i
remembered that it's a bi-money mission
and
never resigns
part of his fighting spare so let's go
directly into the b pairings christian
absolutely in the b group we have tigran
harold union who has been struggling in
this event he already lost two games and
is sitting on only half a point after
three matches he's playing the white
side against brandon jacobson michonne
tipoff is having a fierce fight against
zhu zhang chow christopher you versus
camille dragoon john burke who lost
yesterday in a difficult battle against
guillermo vasquez will be facing nikko
checkout with the white pieces today and
jj alima randy your ex-student is
playing guillermo vazquez and this is
actually
the key matchup that we have our eyes on
alejandro what can you tell us about
this matchup it's a classic matchup
guillermo is a
studios player he just became gm not
that long ago actually uh and he has
been
maybe bored two or three in uh in the
collegiate events for a while but
suddenly he shut up in rating he's
crossed 25 50. he's become the clear
number one player at his university
university of texas at dallas and he's
having a good event here with a plus one
score meanwhile jj he's improved a lot
uh from his
uh collegiate tenure he actually joined
slu at 24-60 and is pushing he was an
international manager an international
master as well yeah not even a full gm
and he's pushing 25 50 at the moment uh
he has had a really good series of
results including an incredible uh
streak at the final four where he was
instrumental for st louis university
winning the national championship and
he's sporting a great looking i mean
this one look at that one that is an
aronian level shirt
i like it
there's a lot of it it's a little
confusing actually we do have another
shot of jj maybe we can switch to the
fifth one
you remember the one that we uh
discussed yesterday maybe
maybe vasquez is blocking him right now
vazquez is potentially blocking him
right now and by the way vasquez i saw
him in the gym today around 7 30 a.m
that is crazy i'm waking up at 7 30
because i'm jet lagged i just came from
europe but the guy was running his mind
off at 7 30 a.m this just goes to show
how ambitious this young player is
that's true we got we got the
we got the shot we wanted it's a little
locked but it's still look at that look
look at that shirt i love it sure all
right let's get into their games because
i'm actually curious on how they're
doing absolutely so we're going to move
to that one the one between alimorandi
and vasquez quinto f3 was the last move
the one that you just saw i see ericom
b7 already oh my goodness what is this
what is this mess all right so i say
rook to g8 it just feels like the
natural way to continue for black yeah
just to try to put some pressure on uh
white's king because obviously after
rook to g8 you have a clear threat you
want to take on g2 and you cannot take
back with the queen because it will to
g8 yeah and then queen e1 becomes a
little more
that's another problem yeah queenie one
is a move right now you could take on c3
but you don't actually don't want to
trade no you're gonna made it no no no
no no well first of all seven first yeah
mating couple of moves yeah yeah so you
don't you don't want to pick up this
knight that queen kind of has to stay on
h4 i don't see another move that's not
rook g8 maybe knight f6 i'm bringing the
knight to e4 right
you can also bring it via g3 i agree
with that i like the move rook g8 it
controls a lot of
important squares
and it asks the question
of white that
his king is weak
and it's not just
playing on black's king
and and just to kind of uh
um drill your point after knight to f6
the problem is that it just feels like
you're giving me one extra tempe that i
really need and right now i'm going to
be able to bring my knight into play
because now i go to f4 if i get to f4 i
just have a feeling that that knight is
going to produce a lot of unpleasantries
for your position not only that but it
also nicely defends the king the white
king the high the king is going to hide
on h2 pawn on h3 nicely protected so by
the way route to g8 was played by
vasquez and i'm wondering if uh
white is an actual serious danger
perhaps you have to go back perhaps you
have to go back
but now i can go knight to f6 right and
knight to e2 cuts the action of the rook
that might be a problem now
what you can do on the other hand and
he's actually going rugby too or to be
to his own it's on the board yeah right
yeah okay so knight to f6 how do you i
think you have to also play knight f6
and
it's kind of curious by the way knight
to f6 or knight to g3 knight to g3 is
also a serious contender because you are
threatening to take the pawn on h3 i
agree with that the only reason i don't
didn't particularly like knight g3
initially was because 92 you don't have
rook takes g2 which was so devastating
in the other variation here since the
rooks are not connected i can disconnect
my rooks as well
and i don't know if it's good or bad for
black but
at least i get either i trade off your
knight which is nice or i get my knight
to f4 which is also nice so i go here
and i go knight f4 and i go knight g5
and either i'm okay or i'm just lost
yeah correct so my idea is that if you
go here i'm going to take take and now i
can take this right maybe i have to go
queen f1 instead of king queen g3
abba you take with chuck
that's unfortunate yes i forgot about
that's a good point yeah check here
check and now you take with check it
looks like you're gaining my queen but
actually you're just simply losing
you're just losing here it's kind of
funny
not that we're going into an end game
because this end game would actually be
winning for white you're not in time to
catch the pawn but i can just simply
take on e3 and i think this is pretty
much over
um
now alejandro while we get into uh the
meat of these games uh tell us a bit
about the price funds
for these tournaments well we have some
handsome prize funds here for the
players definitely helps them out in
their chess careers we cover a lot of
their expenses here but they also get to
come out of this event not just with
experience and rating points but also
with some money six thousand dollars
four thousand and three thousand are the
top three for the a group uh pretty bad
pretty good and uh up to ten place which
is a thousand dollars meanwhile in the b
group it's something
a little bit less because well they're
not quite 2600 yet but 4 000 for first
place is not a bad result at all 2500
per second and 2 000 for third
quite nice handsome price fun um in both
of these events and as we can see ilia
smearing right now benjamin gledura just
pacing throughout the playing hall and
by the way this is not our usual playing
hall no it's not the chess club is uh
undergoing renovations right now we are
expanding this is
a former uh restaurant it's a former
restaurant it's actually a former vodka
bar which is kind of funny
uh called sub-zero
and well
we
we went there pretty often it looks
great and it looks great the renovation
that they did to this looks amazing the
tournament hall uh doesn't even look
like a temporary tournament hall it
looks like a full blown this is where we
play chess kind of kind of place
wow wow look at that camera movement you
see that technology
technology take homology
um and who is that gentleman in a suit
that is past was that your student
nicole the other perhaps nico might be
innocent today yeah all right let's take
a look at some games i'm actually
curious because we have so much fun
chess for you guys today uh i think abi
mario is just dead but in the b group
there's a few games besides the jj game
that are really heated up and i think we
should start with christopher ew against
kamil dragoon
because we have this craziness going on
in this position where black is
currently down a piece
but
he has a lot of tactical shots uh
available in the position currently he
has a pawn for the piece which might be
important so you start calculating rook
f8 is interesting knight e3 is
interesting and by the way just to uh
pinpoint the last sequence of moves
after knight takes e5 yeah so bishop to
g3
knight e5 was played
giving up a piece in one move knight
takes e5 you cannot recapture back with
the knight because the queen is hanging
but rook to f2 came on the board maybe
uh move that the young christopher you
missed let's see rook takes f2 bishop
takes f2 and now king to f1 if you do
take on f2 i have a feeling that after
taking
perhaps queen takes g2 and then queen
takes f2 is actually made it's like a
pinball right now picking up absolutely
everything now let's go back a couple of
moves of course after bishop to f2 yeah
you want to go to h1 no because
well
oh my goodness check this move out you
know what else what's also cool it's
even cooler knight e3
knight eats oh
nice
nice so now if you take boom check these
bishops out
nice one
so king to f1 came on board yeah this is
what we currently have in the position
and i have to say it's just a plethora
of options for a black at the moment
knight xh2 is one of them and i think
this is the danger for dragoon right now
is that he has so many options and he
has ten minutes left and he has to
choose something yes but you know that
if you make the right choices most
likely you are going to check materials
yeah you do have the feeling that it
should be winning here but i don't quite
i can also just pick up your queen if i
the thing is it's three pieces exactly
right that's probably not what i want
it's probably not what you want to do
because you do this takes takes and
i mean you have three pieces for the
queen as white you can give a check but
then i just then i just hide going to
the shell
on g1 hi there and it does feel like it
is actually white who has
the better size yeah it would really
come down to whether you can play d6
here i think but d6 i can even go bishop
to e2 first
maybe that's why i should not start with
the check
like go uh right yeah
and if i go here now you have queen to
f5 even this knight f3 it doesn't seem
right it seems like white is pressing
definitely maybe definitely definitely
white somehow i don't like knight e3 but
what else can we play because rook f2
rook fade was the other serious
alternative so let's see what what's
happening after this one i could take on
chief with what four with the
is the question tonight i think because
let's just look at it but if i take with
the queen
bishop takes g3 i can't move my knight
back you cannot go knight to f3 because
you lose the queen that's right and i
cannot go to g1 because it's made that's
a mate yes but if i go to the e file
then you can all only go to these yeah
but then queen takes e5 is checked
that's another check and i don't even
have to keep calculating yeah i mean
this is just lost it's going up two
bishops i'm going to pick another one i
can probably check my two in the
meantime yeah rook to f3 is coming
the issue that i had by the way he's
actually gone for this going into this
one interesting but the thing is i
didn't see anything better because if
you uh
if you go for this line and i take on g4
with the knight right it looks like
bishop thinks g3 is good for black but
then after king g1 this knight is
holding h2 and i couldn't find the move
here
looks kind of silly but actually white's
pretty safe here i do have another check
but then you can just
go away doodle
and i just didn't see the follow-up here
yeah it's just a check it's just going
to continue but that's not really not
even very good yeah so maybe maybe he
didn't find anything better and actually
went into this variation we didn't like
it they're going into this d6 line uh
and now of course i mean knight to f3 is
also a move right yeah yeah you could
start with knight f3 i don't think it's
a bad move yeah i i just didn't want to
allow you to mess up my structure but
actually if you do mess up my structure
you're giving me also your light square
bishop which is probably a much better
piece than my knight um i don't think
you want to take i don't think so either
i agree with with your explanation of
that
so
no but that but the white's just better
here right it just feels like it just
feels like the pieces should dominate
the queen
yeah one thing about the queen in this
type of imbalanced uh positions
materially in balanced positions is the
queen needs targets yeah and i don't see
any big targets for the queen the king
is actually on f2 not as unsafe
as it looks at first sight because i can
just simply later on as i
defend the knight on f3 i will go to g1
then i can cover any sort of checks on
these diagonals with bishop to f2 and
for the pieces i actually do have
targets myself because right now if you
do go e5
then i can just simply go bishop to e4
or something along those lines and then
you will have to suffer the pawn on d6
is most likely going to get lost not
only that but if you do play e5 and try
to defend the pawn on d6 also the square
d5 becomes extremely weak yeah i agree
with everything you said the position
balance is having to cheat a little bit
with the engine um
don't tell that to our viewers alejandro
because everything that we said makes
sense to both of us and the engine just
thinks were completely wrong
which is kind of funny don't tell me
black is just much better
no but if we go back to the position
before d6
there was this like
inhuman rook fade rooker fade is sure
correct king ji won i mean we're playing
g1 automatically yeah the engine doesn't
play king g1 because apparently queen g5
is winning
but good luck
good luck as i said this is winning
again it's all about the targets for the
queen right and this is exactly what it
comes down to and right now
i guess you probably have to go knight
to f3 back no but then you're just
taking but then it's probably going to
be too much right that's just too much
yeah
not only uh that is too much but most
likely we will get some rook take g3 at
some point yeah and the current position
the engine evaluates it as equal but i
have to say it's a type of equal i would
always take uh white white yeah not even
close same for me same for me all right
let's start the engine off and continue
going through the games we saw jj
vazquez we saw you dragoon let's go to
misha and people's game because it's
also fascinating pretty wild as well
um wow i'm not sure wild for
who so what's the material balance we
have two pieces as for black for a rook
and a pawn and a pawn
that's not that much pawn is getting
ready to go to h7 but
that will always give me uh the g7
square for my bishop so yeah at the
moment the pawn has to stay on h6 i have
to prepare but actually perhaps i do
have a big threat and that is queen to
c3
um to get ready to go h7
c3 might be a bit of a threat yes i
agree with that
because what you don't want is get the
knight back to each no no it's too
passive
no i agree with you actually queen c3 is
a surprisingly
strong threat in this position so why
don't we try to defend against that
activate the queen at the same time yeah
i was just worried about
a3 in this position
so maybe i should go to
a5 right
because this just gives you basically an
extra move
not only that that but i have a feeling
that you have some tricks like this
probably
um what about like the super suicidal
bishop takes g4s just doesn't work right
no way taking that pawn is
dangerous first of all what if i did
this
yeah okay let's start with the mating
threat how do you defend against now
here's my idea was to play f5
this isn't the difference that without
the pawn on g4
i'm i'm still not convinced what if i go
here
yeah but this is a this is a it's a mess
that's a mess it's a complete mask it
might be winning for white but it's a
mess it could also be winning for black
you have to add h7 or something like
that
it's a weird position very unclear who
who gets who gets through yeah yeah
um
[Music]
it looks like you're just being greedy
but actually you also have this idea to
meet h7 king h8 queen to c3 with bishop
to g7 if this bishop is still on c8 then
i just have queen to hg7
i just noticed that
the main thread of white in this
position is h7 yes
h7 is a strong threat yeah h7 king h8
and queen c3 and bishop g7 you just
sacrifice the queen get another queen
with checkmate
yeah that's actually really funny so
let's just actually let's just show this
because it's quite pretty
boom boom
boom get my second queen with a
checkmate big threat
that black has to defend against so so
we'll probably say this throughout the
broadcast i am keeping tabs on the chat
thank you everybody that's participating
either on twitch or on youtube we do
think the pieces usually are stronger
and like in general we think three
pieces are stronger than the queen in
almost every position everything else
being equal
but uh
not on the one that we saw and just to
remind everybody that unfortunately ray
robson did get covet so he has withdrawn
from the tournament all his results so
far will be annulled and
uh and moving forward yeah we kind of
move forward yeah
um his results will be on moving forward
as well so it's not a loss
it's not a gain of rating for his
opponents no it's just zero
no for me sure it is for mishra it is
yes for the games that have been played
those will be reported to fide and this
actually group a that is turns into a
nine player round rob yeah it basically
means moving forward that everybody gets
a bye everybody that plays frey would
normally uh will now get a buy yep all
right uh excellent where should we
alejandro let's uh move on to group a
right yeah
zero idea what the evaluation of the
position is
we'll give them another few minutes yeah
just to kind of stabilize what's
happening and then
tell us show us the way yeah because we
have so much chats we haven't even
touched group a and we're already like
half an hour into uh
to the broadcast absolutely so um
we assessed beer versus uh mishra as
probably winning
for uh beer for white i mean yeah we can
probably switch into into
right now there we go
so he did pick up two pawns um actually
after knight to b6 queen takes b4 came
on the board as we anticipated a5 queen
takes a5 and now rook to a8
we assume that this queen is going to
retreat back to b4 at the same
time do you have any other alternatives
i don't think that you need an
alternative when you have the move queen
before
right but the question is why is he
thinking because actually he just
thought what he just fought for what he
thought for 10 minutes so there was
something that he was calculating he
just took on a8
check this move out alejandro did you
expect this
what i take it from your silence that
you did not um
knight takes a8 rook to d8 i would
assume let's let's let's let's go on
what about here yes
we're not missing anything let's just
calculate
um
so he's going to take on uh right no you
don't want to give a check
oh there's some wait wait wait wait wait
there are some rook takes c5 ideas here
all right let's let let's find the rook
take c5 ideas takes e5 or take c5 oh c5
okay
no there aren't you're not meeting me
with this material configuration there's
no mate it's not only that but you can
just simply take and made you yeah
check
and buy the yes okay knight xa8 is on
the board i mean you have to right
otherwise you're hanging so what if i
just take on c7 perhaps this is it just
a simple root xc7 followed by b4
maybe this transition is what he's
looking at
but it's not so easy right and i think
he took on c7 yeah no actually i think
it is no
no no no no no it's easy no but how do
you proceed
what do you take with with the knight b4
and the knight d5
that's fine i take with the pawn
when the knight f4
knight of four's a huge issue
huh
i mean if you have to take with the rook
and i got queen a4
okay let's try to be smart about this
but how how i just don't understand why
hitting a queen before can we go back to
that
i'm like super confused
with the move uh queen takes aaa
right can i just go queen before what am
i missing here probably knight d5 he was
afraid of
afraid i'm afraid yeah no but 95 rook
takes d5 is game over
you usually resign it has to be rk-4 no
but by the way also
is this a move no yeah everything's a
move
everything's i think like once you play
the knight as well i think queen b4 it's
rook a4 it's the only reason you
wouldn't go for that variation by the
way we're going straight into that line
this is the position we currently have
on the board they did play the move b4
wow
okay so i guess 95 rook takes c5 is
going to be the move
wow that'll get queen to a4 right and
how easy
is this i don't think white's even
better
really oh my goodness that
because if i if i take both of your
pawns you're not better but how do you
prevent me from taking both of your
pawns
the problem is that you have this
balance by the way i wouldn't say that
you're not better if you do take both of
my pawns
because i will take on f6 you probably
have to take back
with the pawn and then if i manage to
find the right configuration the bishop
coming to g3 h3 the king is safe on h2
and then if i manage to double up my
rooks on
the seventh then you're in trouble
really yeah i don't think it's that easy
even that but oh but make a move
okay so knight to d5 just seems like the
only i don't see another move yeah you
have to play knight d5 and i have a
feeling mishra is on the verge of
playing
move the only move i can think of i mean
going knight a6 i'm pinning your other
knight and losing f6 doesn't make any
sense you have to go knight d5 so what
we're saying is that if you take
knight to f4
that's just too strong that's a threat
you the only way to defend against it is
with f3 and now knight to e2 and at
least you're going to pick up this guy
which uh is probably going to give you
at least
it's probably only a growing chance it's
probably only equally equally yes yes
yes
so
so you have to think about the
queen
such a complicated
mess
but that's the thing it's becoming a
mess and i thought queen before was just
poof
yeah right it was poof indeed
um
strange
strange mess here by beer
i mean at least it's it's not a miss
though that that that's the thing it's
not a miss he thought for like 10
minutes
it's very strange yeah when he had such
an easy alternative which is going to be
four
but why we might be missing something
okay queen to b4 let let's just go back
just for a second i know it's it's not
that relevant because the moves have
already been played but
going to be for knight to d5 what do you
do ah queen to b4 rook wave no no i've
been saying rook a4 forever but the
problem with rook a4 is queen d2
i i saw rook a4 but then i saw queen d2
and i thought it was just game over and
then i go check on d8 and i trade queens
and everything you also pick up my uh
yeah pick up my rook in the process
so this is winning i cannot take on h4
i have to do something first
but if i take this
it's the same thing right i just take on
c7 check
then you drop the bishop and you're
winning
so we cannot go into this as either
if those moves are not possible then the
only thing i can think of is knight t5
so let's go into knight to d5
and to be honest after this 95 i really
was so what's wrong with brook takes the
possibility if i rotate d5
i'll just root the xd5 like this yeah
and just resign right i'm down you're
done too much material
it's over right yeah i mean if you take
i take creating another you can't even
hit the rook on c1 you cannot even go
queen to d2 you're completely busted and
completely busted i'm so confused i see
like d5 on the board this might be a big
miss by the by jonas beer okay i'm gonna
peek at the engine
queen to b4 plus seven i mean come on
like i'm telling you i'm telling you
that something had to be missed that
there's no way this engine is so clear
yeah no no but quickly
and on route k4
or plus seven by the way just missed
this move queen oh quindito is not the
strongest move it might be strong enough
you can just go rook to d8 and then
knight d7
e7 here
but like every move is winning rookie 8
is winning take on f6 is winning
some crazy stuff here i understand this
is crazy but so many other moves also
won like i was picking on your engine
and it said queen before rookie for
queen c3 easiest move easiest move no
tactics because you just take on c7 and
take on c5 yeah but here we are wow
mishra might be back into this game the
magic of misra wow what a guy by the way
while we were analyzing this game
glendura versus sam savion finished into
a draw and let's see what happened
um
i'm just going to scroll really quick
through this game yeah this is a very
well known
nimzo line becoming all the rage
actually savion played this against book
in the sochi uh world cup last year yeah
yeah yeah he he played it with the white
pieces right with black actually with
black it was black yeah so he had the
same position so he was the this was the
game that he needed to make a draw to
to advance qualify to qualify the next
round okay bishop to f5 bishop to e2
nothing happened at this point and
probably nothing will be happening
for the duration of this game exchange
exchange exchange white does have a pawn
at this particular moment but black does
seem to have enough compensation for it
queen takes f5 rook to c3 targeting both
pawns the e3 and the b3 and this is
enough for equality yeah this was well
calculated by savvy and you just take on
b-side and you can defend it yes it's
done all right nice nice game there this
one was easy now let's move on to this
uh hey christian okay can you can you
show the audience which pawn white is
attacking on the apartment game is there
like a particular weakness that a
piranha is focused
on
my god this poor pawn on e5
it's getting targeted they're really
piling up on it yeah
i mean like everything pawn to g5 to
isolate it every white piece to attack
it
look it has a funny position if if if
you uh go and teach like a completely
new beginner chess
and you want to see
how much potential they have
you show them this position
and you ask them
what is white's target in this position
and if they don't tell you the pawn on
e5
then you send them to tennis there is
there's no there's no hope yeah
go play tennis go play tennis go play go
swim oh my god something else this
is pretty weak but can you ever take it
the thing is it comes down to the
principle of two weaknesses right
if you don't actually take this pawn if
i black and just stay the rest of the
game defending it right but
uh and what other target do you have
it doesn't feel like white has quite
enough here at some point you have to
create a second wheel you have to create
a second entry point either with h5 or
something on the queen's probably h5
yeah probably h5 right
and it does by the way
time the time situation is
completely equal right now well not
really um white does have
one minute less
they're playing relatively slow yeah 24
minute 24 move sorry for both sides you
can see both of these players sharply
dressed
um
i don't like
my student's position here with black
it's just a little too passive
but
you still have to prove it as white it's
not so easy actually you do you do have
to prove it is um
and this is exactly why he's thinking
for so long grisha aparing that is
because at some point you do have
to make a commitment yeah yeah h5 here
the chat is right there's an alakan gun
gun
rookie iii rook on e4 and i think black
is preparing for
his counter of the kind
rookie six rookie seven put the queen on
the eight of course that's not gonna
happen it doesn't make sense but that's
very nice it's pretty funny that is
indeed very nice um
yeah i mean big moment is going to come
in just a few minutes maybe the next
move could be h5 how do you respond
after h5 there's a couple of actual
uh responses to that i was thinking of
h6 even maybe g takes h5 i didn't
initially like h5 knight h4 yeah
right yeah yeah i don't like allowing
the knight there
so i was thinking h5 h6
h6 yeah if you take on g6 i'll take back
with the rook
and what if i take here i'll just take
back
and here i i mean i was too lazy to
calculate but i i was kind of not
calculating
i was kind of assuming you cannot do
this because too many of your pieces are
hanging i'm not calculating right now
i'm just guessing
it's not my pc so i don't even rookie 5
is okay actually rookie five and then
bishop takes e3
and then i think five is hanging at the
end
take take and unfortunately i cannot
take because you have bishop f2 and this
end game actually is losing for white
yes it is losing for a white so you
actually have to take with the queen but
it will be just
none of this will happen because white
played the move b4 which honestly i like
a lot more uh b4 is a very controlling
move the point is that this part on a6
it might not be in a good square
you might have issues defending this
pawn in the long run i really like the
move before yes it puts a little coming
on a file
yeah you never know when this is going
to be useful i really like that yep i
like it eight minutes 45 seconds this is
going to be quite a tense uh game moving
forward but i'm hearing that actually in
the b group
it does seem like john burke a game that
we haven't seen as much of against nico
checker he found some good moves were
being told by the producers and to be
honest well black is just lost i mean
you have to take this queen and
i'll take this bishop next move and
that's just resigning i mean you're
talking two points
okay so let me wait you're not down to
points you're down one point and then i
take like but then rook takes a6
but
oh yeah yeah it's just two points yeah
that's that's that's the big problem
that's the most cannot recapture f8
would be a checkmate
um
yeah yeah no it does seem like but how
did we get here because it seems like
white sacrificed a piece in a very
interesting way all right let's see
so here bishop takes b6 yeah because he
allowed this bishop b3 line right he
could have gone queen f2 or rook takes
f7 creating an immediate threat
rook to f8 or queen aid bigger threat
yeah that's that's that's a really big
threat yeah
and you don't you can't actually defend
on the king side too easily either no i
mean you're getting mated you can go
with h6 and pray that rook g7 doesn't
win right
but also i can just simply quickly most
likely go this way yeah rook f8 is
probably close to winning i do have a
lot of pawns i have to say yeah that's a
good points too as part of these pawns
maybe taking the third one but there
might be something easier there might be
just a media checkmate we don't know
right yeah
all right well he did play rook to d2
king to h3 rook to d8 back defending the
eighth rank
uh rook to b7 and nowadays that's just
transition from a winning end game yeah
even on h6 i also had rugby seven oh
they all worked yeah no so
this is quite easy very nice very nice
game for john burke he needs this wink
to uh bounce back into the tournament
remember that he lost yesterday to
vasquez
so he does indeed yeah an important one
here for jumbo we have a picky camera
for this matchup
wow
look at this hq
hd cameras the magic of television as
yasser likes to say
yes
all right well this is by the way
another collegiate matchup uh webster
versus yale yeah webster versus yo they
actually i don't think they've ever
faced in a collegiate tournament but
it's a it's a classic
all right uh moving back to the a group
because i
don't think we've watched this one
between you young yi
yeah the service there smearing he
started off shaky you young but then in
the second round a huge victory with the
black pieces against gregory oparin
followed up in the third round but
by a narrow miss against ray robson it
was just an incredible thing i mean
yesterday we signed off at 5pm and they
were still playing
hours later hours later they were still
playing uh he actually got a completely
winning position he actually was made in
14 at some point he had made him 14
against ray robson yesterday in a
complex queen and pawn one of the queen
and two pawn singers queen and pawn and
game
and
ray suffered and suffered and suffered
and almost out of a miracle held a draw
from what should have been a much easier
draw throughout the uh throughout the
game you shouldn't have allowed a
passport by your knee but they played a
marathon yesterday and then after that
ray got covered
and new young he is now here so they
must be exhausted absolutely
is here pressuring again he's playing
against elias mirren and he's obviously
in the better side of the end game he
has an extra pawn
and more importantly than that i think
that
black really needs to find a way to
defend h7 before he loses that one too
big threats for uh white rook to h6
maybe will be mad biking to g8 so
and to be honest perhaps
the pawn on h7 is not even black's
biggest worry uh black's biggest worry
at least the way i see it is
this c pawn starting to move down the
board that might be true um so
the way i see rook to c6 might be
white's next move if you allow me to go
there rook to c6 you have to remove the
bishop from this c3 blockading square
and then just simply go c4 c5 the more
advanced the pawn gets the more
difficult your defense gets
so bishop to d2 was played
now obviously c4 doesn't work because
that would just allow bishop takes f4 so
how do you defend this pawn do you go
king to g4 actually
how you defend this pawn might be a very
tricky question right now
what if i just go f5 you can go f5 yes
but i wasn't sure if i want to do that
f5 and now bishop back to c3 but now i
got rook c6 and i followed right you're
good
you go here but now i have a feeling
that after bishop to f6
what do you do
you go c4 right i guess
c4 right now can i invade
are you going to try to make me
uh i'm going to try to hint at not
necessarily mating you but just kind of
make things awkward for your pcs yeah
this is not so fun actually for white
for example if you go rook to c7 i can
just go back is this a game of draw yes
it's not far away right no it's not
enough
you need three squares three files in
between the pawns
with only two files in between the pawns
this is always a draw yeah because the
king can actually catch both pawns at
the same time with the bishop so if this
pawn would be on b4 then probably and i
think it's a win yeah
even though i don't guarantee that even
with the h even with the h one i think
that's the win yeah
yeah
we don't guarantee any of this
we don't guarantee anything that we say
on the show you said in the show take it
with a grain of salt
all right bishop to d2 is on the board
yeah we'll let spearon um suffer here we
let's go back to the interesting things
in group b because i think they're
running out of time absolutely
particularly the christopher u game
against dragoon i want to see how that
progressed
we still have three pieces for
christopher but
things feel like they've gone south for
white uh first of all he lost the pawn
somehow
his pawn on c4 is gone that's an
important pawn but more importantly
ah these two pawns in the center they're
very if i managed to get some d5 in you
get d5v4 in and by the way
uh
this might actually finish in next move
because they've been repeating the
position for the past two moves uh yeah
because king e3 here right
so king to e3 queen now i think there's
a big threat bishop to d5 right you
cannot just like
play around um
queen to c5 king to e2 once again if i
manage to establish
this control with bishop to d5 followed
by bishop to f2
then you might get in trouble
so
perhaps this is what the players are
saying right now that is just equal it's
just equal
it's hard to assess this from a human
point of view i mean we're not very well
prepared for these kind of positions
where the material imbalance was so big
and white's king is also so exposed but
obviously it can't get made it is just
exposed and black's not really running
any risks in this position but
i feel that
with the time control as it is three
minutes for dragoon
it might be
too difficult to say no to the draw
king 3 was played
is that is that a third time or is that
i think that's that's already the third
position right like that he could claim
with queen c5
that is the third repetition with queen
c5 he needs to wait for queen c5 so
black right now
has it in his pocket has to draw if he
wants it in his pocket he stops the
clock he goes to the referee he says
with the move queen to c5 i'm going to
repeat the position for a third time
they will
check if that
statement is true and then they will
shake hands and make a draw that is the
correct way
to claim a drug or he could play any
other move and then we'll continue the
fight that's another option as well
out of which i mean you could play king
h8 and just continue all right let's go
back to that mish oh my goodness misha
versus zhu zhang chao
okay
because uh that one was pretty crazy
right well still very crazy to e4
h7 was a big threat why is that a piece
white is still down a piece yes how did
this happen by the way where did we
leave it wait wait wait wait wait wait
what
so after knight xe4 this is where we
left yeah
you see this move knight take c4 and you
assume queen take c4 comes
instantaneously no rook to e1
what
[Laughter]
rook to e1
what is that move
allowing
who who thinks of this type of moves
rook to e1
followed by bishop to f5
this is not how you play chess in
general
knight to g3 is an option to pick up the
rook but i would assume for whatever
reason this doesn't work because yeah
yeah i think i see it because of what
like rook to e8 i think it's h7
h7
and then
yeah you have to go
in g7 i'm not sure where i have that
doesn't matter can you do seven on the
other transpose
well i actually want to go here and then
queen c3
oh but now bishop g7 is just easy what
am i saying is this
no it's it's made right bishop g7 rookie
eight
oh my goodness king h7 this is a mate
queen h3 check no queen here right first
because queen h3 bishop h6
and here i think you give a check
what is this mess okay so check you go
here and then rookie seven but you have
king g8
but king g8 i can just simply take right
you take two
and then i go here nothing simple about
that i'll tell you that i mean it
doesn't seem like white's better but i
don't know if you escape the perpetual
i might be better actually as black
as white oh
i just want to run away you might you
might you might be winning i mean
i don't know this is kind of crazy who
thinks because you don't have rook e1
what a move rook to e1 crazy move
i mean and the response was bishop f5 oh
my god i mean the the uh the chat is
telling us rookie one is the best move
wow so apparently one was correct that's
kind of insane
so what do we have in this position
well white is down a piece please for a
pawn
you could potentially take that pawn on
h6 right now
but i have a feeling
you will maybe get checkmated if you do
that okay let's see let's see let's see
how how do i get made it let's look you
don't have any pieces
all right rook do you want
no but rookie one king of fate right
that's the problem yeah
but even
even so i do have a follow-up at least
what a mess
yeah i cannot defend queen in shade i
can go king e7
but even here you have rookie one and
maybe even queen f6 next
you have to go here and then i go here
looks like mate
i think
yeah i'm not sure what it looks like so
if you go here you have queen e7 yeah
this is probably winning no but so what
we can fight
no no
kings here
i can't defend it it's defended that one
is defended
and the idea being that if you do take
on h6 i think you have queen b4 counter
attack right before even queen d8 and i
thought i mean we just play for all
results queen d8
threatening hinting at the idea of going
to h8
um
yeah yeah what complete mess complete
math complete madness here
is there something we're missing here
let's go a little not sure a little
slower
one minute and 30 seconds oh my god to
navigate this position for zhu zhang
chow two minutes
for misha on tipoff and still 15 moves
to go that's insane
this one is going to finish before the
time control i mean there's no way
that's my prediction there's no way both
sides survive to time control here one
of them
queen a5
move what queen to a5 what
i get it you want to control the c3
square
um
i see yeah so on rook g1
you go simply king
you have to go k8 right
i don't know if you go king h7 check and
but why did that hurt me and then i go
here ah and on bishop h6 you have queen
and then i go here no but then queen d2
ah queen to d2
queen to h2 then no but in queen
again my goodness
okay let's not go that fast
king to h8 yes h7
h7 bishop h6 only move yeah
because i was threatening rook to g8
queen here king takes you have to take
it i don't see another give you a check
you have to go back
where's the final blow alejandra i don't
see it i don't see that where is the
fight i mean this queen d2 move is so
important but it seems to be saving
black all the time none of this will
happen because king h8 is on the board
after g1 not king h7 we didn't know why
not but it's not there now
same thing right queen g2
bishop takes h6 i don't see how this
works g2 bishop takes h6 promise queen
d2 is coming next move and that's kind
of the end of white's position that is
exactly why zhu zhang got his queen to
85 actually very clever let's move queen
a5 and not to b4 because you can start
with a3 and now you would have b
right cutting the action of the queen
you don't have
b4 right now
i don't see it
i just don't see it
no no okay so
cuento g2 is not the only move right
no you have others you have h7 you have
b3 h7 is going to be met with queen what
do you play
wow
we're not we're guessing we're casting
zero moves
in this game
queen h
well right now you don't have
queen bishop queen to d2 you actually
don't have a very good placement for
your queen you could potentially return
go back i think queen d8 doesn't move
here yeah yeah but no
because h7 i have bishop g7 bishop to g7
right right i don't see any issues this
you just uh
yeah
okay so
and we might see that let's see what do
you do after queen to d8 if my queen
goes to f6 i think the game is over it's
over right you just defend everything i
think he's going for it yeah queen to d8
was played yep
yeah it's such an obvious move right
you'd retreat that yeah
yeah yeah no i mean
and
was
was there an immediate move
i don't
wait
queen to d8 the queen is still on yeah
queen on the end and then white's
thinking
no this is over i don't i don't see a
difference this is over i don't see not
a defense an attack
it just feels like a piece down your
piece down right you're you're a piece
down oh wow very creative play by misha
antipov but it might not be working out
here at least we don't see how it does
because queen h2 queen d8 an excellent
this is an excellent move by the by the
chinese players
and then queen d8 those are hard to see
queen to g3 we have on the board right
now yeah there's only one move for black
bishop to h6
yeah like everything else is just made
right
automatically
i don't but also i don't get the point
of this move
there is no point the thing is just that
you don't actually have
too many moves right now
i think he wants to play
like on king age seven i think he wants
to go for f6 right and then try for some
kind of
i don't even know what but
it's the only way to continue the game
yeah it just feels like it um if you do
go f6 yourself then i have feeling maybe
some queen to h3 followed by rook to g6
but even that even that right queen of
fade road g6 king h7 and how do you
continue i guess you could go queen to
h5 and say that rook to e8 is not
possible not really it's possible
ah it is possible because you take take
and now i cannot take the rook on eight
because the queen is pinned yeah i
thought maybe you'd go queen h4 but i
feel at that point white is really just
not really threatening much okay you're
throwing a palm but who cares no yeah no
those looks waiting for black this was a
fascinating game but i feel it's getting
to its end because f6
is such an obvious move you don't want
to allow white to get his home pawn to
f6
it's one of only
three legal
moves i mean okay queen of six is also
legal uh king h7
actually also probably wins to be honest
right right right we
but but why yeah
do i have any other alternatives as
white after f6 right after f6 i don't
see them
the thing is material is just too
reduced yeah that's true material is way
too reduced
you only have two pieces to continue
your attack with yeah it's not very much
and it's not enough there's just not
enough i don't think it's enough i think
white black is barely holding but
holding and when you're barely holding
up a piece eventually that piece will
will tell and by the way as
we predicted uh the game between
christopher you and uh cameron dragon
finished it in a draw right it's an
incredible draw repetition we were
predicting
it does seem like he's going for the
king
the hand movement is
hinting at king to h7
no never mind f6 played with four
seconds jesus
four or two i'm not her
how do these players go down on time
like that that's crazy
it was indeed a big moment right yes f6
if you miss something then you lose on
the spot right
but you don't miss anything because i
don't think
there's anything here to miss to be
missed um it's just that you're
balancing your position so easily right
your next couple of moves came to h7
queen to f8
and there's just simply no entry squares
for my pieces
no entry squares and no tactics
no this looks busted for a white
i just don't think so
yeah big move
big big big move by the chinese player
and if you do go work to g6 if you start
like that which he didn't he played
queen to h3
and we're thinking queen f8 right queen
of fate is probably the safest yes yeah
i mean you could you could go king h7
but you see queen h5 and you're
wondering get the queen in place but you
get the queen and play it makes it makes
a lot more sense and he's going for it
yeah queen to f8
played
or g6
roger registers a bit sad because you
attacked the bishop but you realize that
rook has no more moves after that right
right king h7 and then it's very clear
you don't have a follow-up i mean you
would have to make queen h4 work but
there's no way going to h4
and what if i just go rook three yeah
and i was hoping rook f6 and
let's give a check yeah you give a check
i go i have to go to h2 so you don't
have a counter check wait wait yeah yeah
that's fine
so you cannot take because you take no
that's clear
but i go king i don't know somewhere h2
but here queen g7 i'll give you another
i think at that point queen g7 is the
best because rook g6 queen b2 is chuck
yeah queen queen here is the best
threatening yeah the invasion and as
usual these tricks with uh rook h6 never
work
because the queen and the king are on
the same file and the queen gets paid
um yeah this is a pretty sad situation
right now for misha antipov who with
this one
would go down to minus one coming in as
the rating favorite in the event after
round four to be on minus one is not a
great position to be
queen to h5 is on the part
once again rook to e8 we think rookie is
just over yeah and he goes for it he
sees the uh idea trick that after rook
takes h6 you can actually just simply
yeah and once there's once this work is
active
and i think this might be just
resignation question
for
the young player playing under the
feeder flag right now michonne um what's
happening in the game of your student
alimorandi versus vasquez that's an
important one for the standings and it
seems to be a mess they have reached mu
40
which is important
material is equal
and it almost feels like black's getting
mated with a queen d8 or something but i
there's no actual follow-up checks
um
after a check on the g file and queen d8
is not possible because of the knight on
f7
but i could i could push my pawn i could
go c6
starts inviting a lot of chucks though
let's give one of them
yeah queen d2 and the promise i think
you just pick up my pawn either from c1
c3 yeah pick on uh pick the guy on c6
you do have a follow up with knight to
f6 after that but i don't think it's
leading too much yeah i don't think it
leads to a win right let's see this this
go back you take
knight to f6
now i can just simply go king to f8
and then we kind of play for all results
you could even just give it perpetual
and say let's call it a game yep
this feels equal all right
um let's return actually to the a group
and see what's happening actually
nothing has happened almost in the game
between you yangi and ilya smirin is
still
i don't know
maybe maybe some progress yeah yeah
it all kind of
it feels like a lot of progress for
white actually
inviting this movie h5 yeah
because now
is that you gain the g6 square
quite important because you always have
ideas of rook to g6
also you could potentially have ideas of
putting the bishop on g6
and reinforcing
its tenure on g6 by f5
um let's see what he chooses
to do
i think i'll be very tempted to play
rook f7 here
sure
why not
let's create an immediate attack
on the pawn on f4 you have to defend
with
let's go bishop f5 you could go bishop
f5 you could also go over k4 actually
it's a little passive but you'll go
bishop g6 next move i want bishop f5 for
the moment bishop f5 and i'll just you
know i'll keep pushing i'll go h4 you do
okay yeah
jack can i go back to f8 let's go here
and i give a check on
and this game has ended in a draw we did
think it was equal
yes uh so no surprise there between jj
ali miranda and guillermo vazquez
but i think smirn is close to a draw in
this one somehow you do yeah somehow i
feel like i'm feeling
i'll uh i'll take you yangi in this one
i think he's going to be able to convert
now converted
this one
the game between uh oparin and thioderu
once again a few things have happened
actually quite a lot of things happen i
like this last move but first of all i
don't know how but black got rid of his
weakness on a6 correct i don't know how
that happened so after b4 this is where
we left it off
i like h5 actually
oh man black really black really has no
moves like queen d5 queen d6
but as we mentioned maybe that's enough
that's enough yeah you only need to uh
wow
b5 trying to create something out of
nothing i'm going to see it
ah quincy reminding white that he has
some uh
some weaknesses too right now that he
pushed all his pawns forward correct so
yeah i don't c4 was i don't even know if
white's actually better without the a
plane without the a and b pawns that was
yeah yeah right now it is starting to
feel like uh he's losing his uh grip on
the advantage
yeah this feels like it's just equal
okay white can just do whatever and i
don't think black can make progress
right white has to just play a few moves
make time control make sure that he
doesn't have any
hidden gems in the position in which he
can improve his position and then
probably just go into that yeah queen on
c8 is actually kind of annoying
so you want to make a couple of safe
moves uh before you reach time control
especially with only one minute left
but yeah this looks equal and how about
the game between beer and
mishra
oh my
that game 16 seconds for mishra right
now yeah but he only has two moves to
make so it's not that hard to make you
make okay he makes one of them
i just don't feel white's batter here
this knight on d5 is just too strong
at some point
he might even
risk losing why do you mean right why
yeah
yeah yeah some checkmating threats and
if you take i take with the f pawn and
then
promote the port no i i i agree with you
this turned into a three result game
where like i i'm sure that white has a
draw if he wants it i think rook fade is
just to try if he felt like it but
uh
because you cannot really take on
if i go really
okay i keep i hide
oh somehow i missed the square
i hide
there you go king c6 or where do you go
after rick did just king cyber maybe
yeah a king e7 doesn't work because you
take on d5 yeah by the way rook to it
was played with the idea of going to f8
and not giving up the e5 pawn the idea
being that queen d1 is going to be met
by rook to e1 yeah
and that makes move 40 for beer which is
important yes but not for abi manu has
one more decision to make blazing of h4
actually does not care about white's
threats at all
it's also possible why has no threats
i like this move i actually like this
move a lot no no white actually had a
threat
h4 i think was a threat irish was a big
threat yes sorry sorry yeah yeah yeah
because rg5 comes with meat yes yeah
that's funny i was thinking for example
okay let's just make uh
whatever yeah maybe even maybe even here
h4 right problem is that you don't have
time to pick up my rook yeah that's
actually take take but still there's
absolutely no defense against g5 yeah
you can pre-move it quite crazy
you take rook to g5 that's an insane
mate
so h4 is a very good move i love h4 and
as i said i don't think white's better
here i really don't think so yeah
i tend to agree with you on this one
so
as an assessment where we stand right
now
mishra seems to be
finding his way out of the very
difficult situation that he was in
only
15 moves ago now 15 moves i think he was
just lost uh so a very resourceful
player finding some tricks easy to
collapse in such positions but somehow
he's still here still here and fighting
but i have to say
this was beer's fault because b4 was
such an easy move to make it just felt
like the most natural move in the
position and then you start thinking and
you start doubting your decision-making
process and then you could come up with
this move queen to a8 yeah yeah it was
it just invites trouble
right it just invites trouble in the
position there's absolutely no
reason to go into that
all right h4 we have on the board this
one is going to go on for a very long
time both players have made the time
control and uh beer will be pondering
his next move now
let's go back to the b group right where
do we have some time trouble situations
antipov is still playing somehow okay
i'm not only going to tell you that but
i actually cheated because uh
the chat told me something incredible
don't tell me this is a draw that's just
a draw it's not just a draw it's a zero
zero draw
black can make a move unbelievable
and black just can't move
what if i just go rookie three
and then
ah okay so at some point i will take so
apparently white has an actual thread
which is rook g4
rook g4 is a threat yeah
and rook g4 is a threat because of
because queen g for rook h4 actually
wins g6 stroke h4 actually wins
so you have to keep the rock on the
seven you have to keep the rock on the
7th
okay but this makes a lot of sense i'm
actually threatening b5 right or at
least i'm hinting at the idea of winning
b are you sure because if you play b5 i
take twice
what do you do if you think of b5 rook
g4 might win
no way no no but then i go back
then i go back to p7
so let's just make a couple of moves
they take they take take and you say
rook to g4 with the idea queen g6
followed by rook to h4 but then i go
back and if you go here
i hide
with rook to h7 even this i don't
guarantee is better for black
has to be no way what if i just move
king f1 make a move
make one move
i'm gonna start playing for a win as
well i believe you i don't believe you
all the time oh my gosh i think you have
to go queen e7 and just go into the end
game
but you don't have a threat you don't
have a move
that is not true i have queen eight here
though that's okay you have it this way
yeah because now i want to take this guy
and if i go queen g6
i take
and you're i go into the cocoon
and i guess rook h6 doesn't work yeah no
but it's kind of cool this cocoon is uh
it's a suspicious very suspicious cocoon
but it works
even this after takes takes queen h4
bishop h6 queen e7
we're way way way way down the line yeah
but i cannot play this move because of
f6 and you actually win yeah that's
funny that is funny
but i go back into my cocoon
no but then you go here and this is some
sort of uh perpetual yeah
get out of here
this game is ridiculous we found the
perpetual all right
on the board and
unclear if you have a threat a game that
we expected to finish 10 minutes ago
will probably actually go for a very
long time yeah yeah this became from
totally lost to actually equal and we
were completely wrong in our evaluation
i'm wondering
what the assessment is so these players
yeah for the players they don't know
right they have no idea they have no
idea so i checked with the engine
back when we went queen c3 check
was king h7 the right king h9 was the
only way to win oh my which is a little
insane because you don't want to allow i
have sex he wanted to play that move he
wanted to play that much he wanted to he
wanted to play against initially he he
went for it yeah the the king
wow wow
but because of somehow
yeah somehow black just doesn't have
enough resources to get out of this
that's crazy
what a concept what a defensive concept
what a defensive concept black is just
totally paralyzed
wow rook to b7 on the board and we're
going to be
leaving these players to think about the
position yeah they'll be there for a
while
we actually reach move 40 in most games
um
is there any game that doesn't hasn't
reached it
no
no no no they're playing fast today
all of the players are playing fast um
maybe you're paring no they just reached
40.
you yankee long actually just four moves
ago yeah everybody has reached
move forward the second time control
okay
choose the game alejandro allah
i'll give you
you might you might get mad at me when i
choose this one but choose it uh burke
checkout excellent
how's white win this
you're asking very tough questions
i mean usually you win this end games
kind of easily uh as white but proper
technique is to not put your pawn on e7
i mean by all by all means stretch of
the imagination the way you win these
things is usually by cutting the king
right and then you get your own king in
but with the pawn on e7
i don't know how you make progress hmm
kind of voluntarily actually so we got
to this position and yeah he decided to
go
well voluntarily yes but we didn't have
to play e6
but what else um
yeah yeah
i mean you gonna go king g200 k5 for
example
let's start with okay i mean i don't
know
but okay he pushes to e7 perhaps he
thought this was the best
we'll agree with his grandmaster
evaluation and just i just want to know
how you win this at the end the rook c6
on the board no but if i go rook b5 a5
this is just white it just works so you
have to defend against this but then i
just go on the back rank i think you
even just go check and track and then
and you just bring it up but this is the
thing you bring the king in you bring
the keys or you bring the king in that's
why you want the pawn on e5 so that it
creates a shield an umbrella however you
want to do it correct
to the king on e6 this is like how you
win the second game but here we are
rook to c6
not that easy not that easy right okay
so because he's he's running out of
shelter here i thought rogue g6
he might have to go king d5
g6 and if you're on h6 and you lose a
pause you might not draw the game as
black but at least i'll get i'll get a
pawn
and now we have to calculate some races
we have to calculate what happens with
the a pawn where i'm going to hide my
king this became a lot less trivial what
do you do now it might be winning but
it's not trivial so what do you do now
here i take you take i go king f5
and perhaps you give a check right so i
take and now h6 is not possible yeah and
i can i'll even go rook g6 just because
i can
that's funny
that is funny
yeah no that's nice yeah and if you go
king of five then i just keep attacking
your h-pod
that is very nice how do you win this i
mean you're losing your h-pawn
and if i go here actually you continue
with this rabbit rook yeah
yeah and at some point i'll actually
take oni7 like like a normal person yeah
and now this is you are extra in the
square
this is the score and he's actually gone
to e5 out of all places i thought he
just came from there
no he didn't he came from f5 he's got
king e5 instead try to stay close to
the pawns on the king's side yeah so
right now rook c5 i assume just loses to
king d6 kingdom
yeah that has to be losing so he's got
rook c4 makes a lot of sense attacks the
pawns on the king side and king d6 i
have rook d4
again no umbrella for the king right you
want to go king e6 but you have the
issue that rookie 4 is still stupid
so what do you do
what do you do is the big question right
now that
john burke needs to be answering and
it's not an easy answer yeah it's not
it's not so easy right by the way a game
that we completely ignored i mean i
assume white is winning here but it's
going to take him forever to convert you
know it's empty because it's not even
clear whether this is winning or not
anymore it isn't to me
at the very least to me this is not
clear whether it's 20 years when king to
d6
insanity and my guess is that rook to d4
is just going to come instantaneous
ah okay so this is the idea you want to
go rook to d4 and now you're following
with king to e6 and then you get a tempo
at least
on the rook
so then next move i'm just going to push
my pawn
um
and i'm going to do this a few times
okay but okay i just move right
somewhere i don't understand
what do you think whatever
c4 let's put it back by push and i just
gave you a check
no no no no no no g6 g6
g6 i know it looks scary to give up uh
right
that should be winning right yeah yeah
once the king goes to h6 i have a
feeling
this is gonna be winning no i agree with
you maybe rex if i was the better check
they're going into that line they're
going straight into them yeah yeah i
mean once i have a feeling that if i
manage to get the pawn to a6 that has to
be winning
yeah at some point
yeah at some point the rook will win by
itself right you're going to pick up
the pawn a7 and you're just going to get
the rook behind the pawn and then
yep
so at some point does it just turn to
win if this pawn on a
three gets too too far advanced
maybe this was we're going to check it
out easier than we thought
let's see if he's going to continue with
a4
and we can always repeat the same thing
right can you go a4 c5 6. it's just the
same yeah yeah it's the same pattern
um
so the pattern goes something along the
lines of check check boom
knocking e5 so that you have key f5
yes
c4
king to e6 and king to f5 and then we do
it i'm going all over again yeah that's
kind of a funny thing like 20 moves it
might be good enough uh a game that we
kind of ignored unfortunately uh was a
game between harutinian and brandon
jacobson
but
uh it felt i felt that black had a
pretty good position early on but this
this one in particular that just looks
busted uh
this pawn on b6 is too strong and it's
clear which side has the activity so the
only question is whether you can survive
the next move
because rook takes b6 knight c4 is
resigns so you have to go
i guess knight d5
i don't really see another move
no knight d5 seems
like at the right option but then but
give a check and then how do you defend
maybe knight to c4 just simple just
simple
i think simple chess wins games
that's good enough right simple trust
yeah can you find such a huge threat
you have to react to that
um maybe react like this give a check
but then i
now i can give a check back on this
difficulty
points no longer matter i'll take that
work from b8
and you go here
try to claim that there's some sort of a
uh yeah
but i i i think at this point black is
just
prolonging resignation more than
actually creating
a way back in the game right
i don't know i mean i mean even if i go
g5 instead of rook c7 like what is your
name just play it like that just play
like that just just bind black you have
no moves why create threads you don't
need them
just wait for black to uh
right now
it feels like he's in a bind right now
yeah i think he just lost actually
knight d5 is on the board
yeah 95 or 66 king e7 even yeah knight
c4 i think it's just it's just pretty
easy it just feels like
everything to e5 is such a big threat
it's just such a huge threat you have to
do something about it you just don't
have enough resources on the board not
only that but if i do get my king to c5
yeah then this is over everything wins
once i connect the king to the point on
b6
i'm freeing up one of my other resources
and that just gives me a winning
position
um
yeah i mean the difference is in the
activity in the same game we see every
single piece of whites is more active
and it's pure
beautiful display of strategic and
gameplay
by the young player from armenia now
anything has happened in this one no no
so author a6 king to after rook to e7
king to f1 rook to b7 kick to f2
well he can repeat he's just waiting
what's safe
yeah i'm insane safe actually
by the way
is this also a draw
you wanna perpetual immediately
yes
looks like a drop
i mean the problem is
that's not even a i don't even want this
rook i don't want your stinky rook i
want it only if you go queen to f8 now
you want it now i want it i don't know
i'll play green g6 queen g6 just
yeah this is uh a perpetual yeah
yeah it was surprising but uh i think uh
misha and people were completely
underestimated oh my goodness look at
look at the player from china he
realizes right now he knows it he knows
that something this is absolutely wrong
he's looking at the score she's trying
to pinpoint the exact moment where he
lost
the advantage yeah
he's not happy okay how can you be happy
right you're up a piece and it looks
like you're just winning
and then you get to the position after
time control what and you realize that
you are constantly
he's laughing right he's like what
what
he is incredulous right now
he's looking at his opponent he's
laughing he's like
oh man
you got away with murder in this one
yeah for sure i mean
what uh what he's getting away with here
is ridiculous right
that's the same anymore
incredible all right
what
yeah i mean this is exactly what's
happening in this one in in in the berk
versus uh he found a way to win and he's
just going for it right just a four
this is gonna
pan out yeah maybe
and what else do we have let's see oh
this is this one is yes we might
actually have most of the games covered
today sorry
versus jacobson we know where this one
is going after knight to c4 makes a lot
of sense
okay this is the this is the one that we
cannot really say
what the exact assessment is
yeah i mean why it's never worse but
uh the harder you push the more you have
chances of losing
yes that's true i like the fact that
he's keeping the rook on the first rank
yeah i like that too actually because
knight to e3 will probably be met by
bishop takes and then actually rook to
e1 and you might actually lose that yeah
the thing is most i think most end games
where you lose the knight for the bishop
are lost unless you have immediate
counter play with like you know e2 or
something but
you know barring
exceptional circumstances just training
the knight for the bishop should be
a lost end game for
black even though this pawn structure in
particular is good for black because you
have a lot of queen g3
uh queenie one type of patchfuls
yeah all right so going around the horn
in uh group a as well you young he
versus smearing still trying
oh he's still trying definitely going to
try in this one
i don't know how big his chances are but
but he's definitely trying
it'll be here another four hours
i mean they'll be here forever
yeah i know yeah yeah but how
what's the what's the right way to try
at this point do you go f5 do you keep
the pawn on f4 to shield the king to
allow it to go to g5
how do you continue trying to make
progress is the question
i think in this particular position f5
is not very good because somehow you
have to get the pawn on h4 right yeah i
feel like you don't win when there's
the thing is for example f5 rook d4
uh king h5 i want to play but you start
looking at h3 and then you realize wait
a second be careful be careful right
like who's going to catch this guy be
careful so you don't want to be so hasty
but
yeah can you have faith
and uh
i'm getting made it
so i'm having a mating thread
you have a pawn ready to promote to
promote what a mess
you want to give a check for it i can
give a check but you go to h4
right because if you go here i go here
you actually
get into a worse position but you go
here to h4
yeah and bishop g5 king takes h3 looks
locked just trying to find some sort of
uh
some sort of a tactic in the position
but
i don't see it
yeah i don't see it either so if you
don't give this check then you go first
to d8 defend against checkmate
where is my continuation
because this pawn is
still strong yeah once it gets to h2
there's no way it's winning
it's harder to prevent that though
you have to go through k7 and hope that
there's some but this is just uh no but
rookie 7 or d5 i don't even have to
to think about it
yeah yeah this is just perpetual right
there's nothing more than that no yeah
nothing more than that no because h1
comes in yeah
so
this one
you will have to find a different way
when you hold through
a4 you go to k4
because i'm actually threatening that
pawn
now you want to take on h4 if you do
take on h4 it's probably winning
probably starting to look really close
yeah
even that i don't really
know yeah i mean that's opposite our
bishop end game but i have to give uh
the attacker
huge chances to convert that one yeah
yeah
with the rooks on the board and two
points yeah without the rooks we know
it's a draw right but with the rooks
and alejandro as we are getting ready to
sign off for round number four here in a
studio b at the english chess club let's
take a look at the standings we're going
to start with uh
group a results results of group a so
far today remember that ray robson is
not participating in the tournament
anymore he had to withdraw due to covet
which means that adam hakobian had a buy
and that leaves us with the following
benjamin ladura drew samsevian gregory
apart is still fighting it out against
nicolas theodore who our as is jonas
pierre against that mishra actually not
fighting anymore they drew that
oparin and the other have
drawn their nerves
so they drew uh half a point for each
let's let's take a look at group b
in group b we have tigran harutionian
still searching for his first victory in
the event he definitely has great
chances against brandon jacobson
michonne thiepov is pulling a rabbit out
of his hat right now
that's a who did he save against uh zu
zhang chow from china christopher you
made a draw against uh camille dragoon
john burke still duking it out against
nico chica and jj alimorandi has
made a draw against guillermo vasquez
alejandro quite an entertaining round
four tomorrow round five in the books
final thoughts about today's round it's
going very fast and i think that today
in particular we saw
awesome craziness i think this game of
antipov
it was just great oh yeah it was just
great stuff uh we had the grandmother
from tipoff we have the game of mishra
that was very confusing as well uh on
the b group we have a bunch of wild
fights
uh the dragon game was great great game
great game the even the ali miranda game
was great so we had a lot of fun stuff
today i will have a lot of fun stuff for
you guys tomorrow as well so join us
same time same place uh we'll be here at
3 30 p.m central to analyze the games of
um groups a and b
nine nine rounds per day summer chess
classic don't miss it we will see you
tomorrow
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you